what would Wednesday be without all the
dark humor we almost got to find out
[Music]
me one of Netflix's recent success
stories is the original series Wednesday
based on the popular character from The
Adams Family franchise fans adored away
the series star Jenna Ortega has
embodied the Grim deadpan Wednesday
atoms perfected by Christina Ricci in
two Adams Family films in the 1990s
while putting her own unique spin on the
character but according to remarks made
by Alfred Goff and Miles Miller the
show's co-creators and co-writers
Wednesday's signature character trait
was in Jeopardy during the production of
the show while Wednesday's love of the
cube rickster and dark clothing were
kept intact in Wednesday the character's
signature modern's one-liners almost at
The Cutting Room floor you know or
constantly getting those to just
eliminate all the jokes
it might be surprising that anyone would
be interested in doing a series based on
The Adams Family without the franchise's
dark humor a recent interview with Garf
and Miller reveals that just such a
suggestion was made during the editing
process dark humor is a signature rate
of not just a character of Wednesday
Adams but the entire Adams Family
franchise itself going all the way back
to the morbidly funny cartoons by
Charles Adams beginning in the 1930s but
in an interview with geek Vibes Nation
to promote Wednesday series writer
creators Garfield Miller revealed that
one executive suggested removing
Wednesday's dark humor from the series
one exactly wanted to cut all the jokes
out all the black humor all her sort of
references to murder and suicide and
death thankfully Miller realized the
importance of this element to Wednesday
but he credits executive producer Tim
Burton who also directs four out of its
Eight Episodes with nailing its grimly
humorous tone you have one of these
monsters at home steam-powered
guillotine I built it when I was 10.
I wanted to decapitate my dolls more
efficiently whatever the unnamed
executive who suggested cutting out the
dark jokes from Wednesday might have
been thinking it's difficult to imagine
the show or in fact any Adam's
family-affiliated Project without at
least a pinch of morbid humor and given
the massive success of the series on
Netflix with the platform's biggest ever
opening for any Series in the English
language it certainly seems clear that
fans both old and new alike are
responding well to the show's tone
you want to take a stab at being social
I do like stabbing the show's Gambit of
taking Wednesday Adams are sent to be a
comedy character and placing her in a
young adult Dark Fantasy mystery series
complete with magic powers and demonic
Monsters has paid off big time and that
dark humor that makes the show stand out
in a genre is a big reason why but God
says a mix of tones always seemed like a
natural fit even if the exacts at
Netflix didn't always agree for
executives it was scary but for us
[Music]